please allow me to say a few words about
the terrorist attacks on september 11
2001.
i was in downtown chicago on that day
lost in the mundane busyness of an early
tuesday morning at that time i was
already fascinated by human nature
the best and the worst of it
exploring it through the study of
history and literature
in the years before as a young boy
growing up in russia i saw chaos
uncertainty and desperation in the
soviet union of the 1990s
wrapping up a century of war and
suffering
but after coming to america for me
there was a sense of hope
like all of it was behind us
a bad dream to be forgotten as we enter
into the new century
on 9 11 when i saw the news of the
second plane hitting the towers my sense
of hope had changed
i understood
that the 21st century like the century
before would too have its tragedies its
evildoers its wars
and its suffering
and unlike the history books these
stories will involve all of us
they will involve me
in however small and insignificant a
role
but one that nevertheless carries the
responsibility to help
i became an american that day a citizen
of the world
i felt the common humanity in all of us
i felt the unity and the love and the
days that followed and i think most of
the world shared in this feeling that we
are all in this together
evil cannot defeat the human spirit
there were many heroes sung and unsung
on that day and in the years after
often politicians failed to rightfully
honor the service and sacrifice of these
heroes there's much i could say about
that
but i don't want to waste my words on
the failures of weak leaders
instead i want to say thank you to the
men and women who rushed to ground zero
to help who put on a uniform to serve
who make me proud to be an american and
a human being and give me hope about the
future of our civilization
here on a small spinning rock
that despite the long odds
keeps kindling the fire of human
consciousness
and love
you